Я дуже сумувала через те, що я вижила, бо мені було дуже тяжко прийняти себе нову.
Але я зрозуміла, що я зараз хоч і без ноги, але я сиджу і я живу,
і я можу встати й піти, так, з милицями, але можу.
Тож щодня вона встає і виходить на прогулянку рідною Одесою.
Руслані Данілкіній - дев'ятнадцять. Рік тому дівчина вирішила стати на захист України
й добровільно пішла на фронт.
Я більше боялася за те, що я не знаю, куди я їду і на який час я покидаю свою домівку.
От від цього було трішки страшно. Я розуміла, що я не знаю, що буде.
А дуже сильно хотіла, бо це моя країна, я її дуже люблю. І я розуміла, що чим нас більше,
тим ми сильніші. І я розуміла, що я не можу зробити щось велике,
але я можу спробувати, зробити хоч щось. І думала, що хоч мала якась частина
допоможе моїй країні. Тому я зібрала речі і поїхала.
Спочатку Руслані довірили роботу з документами, але вона швидко зрозуміла,
що хоче працювати ближче до фронту. Через юний вік тоді 18-річній дівчині
кілька разів відмовляли. Проте завдяки наполегливості Руслана все-таки домоглася свого
й почала працювати операторкою-зв'язковою. Щоденна служба тривала аж до дня,
який розділив її життя на "до" та "після". 10 лютого Руслана з побратимами
виконували бойове завдання на Херсонщині.
Я була, як завжди, в гарному настрої, все було добре.
Аж раптом почався артилерійський обстріл.
Уламки касетних снарядів поцілили у пасажирське сидіння.
Момент вибуху, і якось несвідомо я сховала голову. І потім я дивлюся,
що я вже тримаюся за коліна, і одразу зрозуміла, що сталося.
Я не хотіла в це вірити, я питала у побратимів, коли кричала:
"Що там?" А відповіді не було...
І якби не медики, які їхали недопадік і вчасно надали першу допомогу,
Руслана могла б загинути від втрати крові.
Я тоді вже зрозуміла, коли переклали мене до буса, то я вже побачила, що нога збоку.
І все, я заплющила очі і їхала до лікарні. Мене там вже прооперували,
бо в мене була дуже велика втрата крові. І звідти мене в той же день евакуювали до Миколаєва,
до більш безпечного міста. У Миколаєві пробула три доби, і вже тоді переїхала до Одеси.
З тих пір, я думаю, що коли я приїхала в Одесу, мені стало якось морально трошки легше.
Я ж вдихнула своє рідне місто, і від того моменту почала боротися за своє життя.
І продовжує боротися щодня. Руслана перенесла п'ять операцій
й нині проходить санаторну реабілітацію.
Знаходжусь на етапі заживлення ноги, перемотую бинтами і знімаю постійно заміри ноги,
коли вона перестане худнути. Тоді вже будемо приступати до протезування.
Завдяки пожертвам вдалося зібрати понад сімдесят тисяч доларів на протез для Руслани.
Хотіли саме Ottobock, тому що він багатофункціональний. У ньому є все:
в ньому можна плавати, пересуватися по піску, бігати довгий час.
І тому ми хотіли саме його, бо з механічним трохи незручно.
І тому вирішили відкрити банку, і люди, які хотіли, допомагали.
Вдалося зібрати дуже швидко. Ми не очікували такого результату.
Завдяки свої жазі до життя Руслана стала одним із символів сили та незламності.
Утім, втрату своєї ноги дівчина прийняла не одразу.
Я не можу сказати точну дату, бо це було так, що ніби ось я прийняла, все гаразд,
я звикла до себе я виходжу на вулицю, пройшлась, приходжу до палати і розумію: "Ні!".
Навіть через 3-4 тижні я вийшла на прогулянку, дивлюся фотографії, мене брат сфотографував
недавно, а я… без ноги. Тобто досі буває таке, що я забуваю.
І я вважаю, що навіть досі немає повного усвідомлення, що от все…
Після трагедії пройшло майже два місяці, але фантомні болі й досі переслідують дівчину.
Я дуже давно відмовилася від внутрішньо-м'язових обезболів сама.
Я прийшла до рішення, що треба припиняти їх пити і відчувати ногу, як є.
І тому я перестала все пити, і фантомні болі повернулися, стали більш болючими.
З часом вони почали притуплятися. Коли я почала бесідувати з психологом,
вона мені почала доносити, як саме я повинна доносити своєму мозку,
що ніжки вже немає, бо він пам'ятає мій образ, який був раніше,
і дає туди імпульс, і через це виникають болючі відчуття.
Попри всі випробування Руслана хоче мотивувати інших постраждалих
від війни людей, аби вони не втрачали віри в життя.
Я хочу жити, я хочу показувати людям те, що це можливо.
Моя найпростіша мрія - я хочу встати на ковзани і поїхати. Я мрію про велосипед.
І якщо в мене немає ноги, це ж не означає, що я все.
Я хочу показати людям, що все можливо, і не треба сидіти і ховатися,
що у вас щось сталося. Це страшно, це боляче,
але життя продовжується, його треба жити.